coronary plastic also called
percutaneous transluminal coronary angioplasty
or balloon enjoplasty
and designed to restore blood flow
through coronary arteries that
have narrowed or are blocked by
atherosclerotic plaques or
blood clots when you arrive at
the hospital you are fitted with a line
intravenously your heart rate is
monitored and you receive it by
oral or
intravenous administration as well as dative which helps
you relax most
coronary angioplastic procedures last
between 30 minutes and 3 hours the doctor
anesthetizes the skin at the level of your
hatred and inserts  a needle in
the femoral artery after placing
the needle a guide wire is passed
through the needle and gently routed
through the arterial network to the
heart the needle is then folded back and
replaced with a small flexible tube
nommy sheath  which allows access to your
femoral artery at this stage you are
given an anticoagulant to reduce
the risk of a blood clot then a
soft flexible catheter is slipped
over the wire and inserted into the
heart the procedure is controlled using
a continuous device
x-ray imaging device called fluoroscope you may
feel pressure as the wire and
sheath are inserted through the groin
and passed through the artery but
you will not feel their movement
through your arteries at this stage your
doctor removes  the guide wire positions
the tip of the catheter inside
the coronary artery to be treated and injects
a specific dye the dye
allows the fluoroscope to take
X-ray images named in geogram of
the interior of the arteries any blockage
will be clearly  identified as the
arteries fill with the dye you
may feel flushed or slightly
nauseous as the dye is injected
once the blockage is identified
your doctor places a flexible guide wire
inside the artery and inserts
a catheter into the balloon  on this thread and at
the site of blockage rapid inflation and
deflation pushes the
vessel wall outwards
thus restoring blood flow through the artery
you may feel
chest pain during this stage the same
procedure is repeated for each
blockage  to treat then your doctor
remove the deflated bloated and the
catheter from your arteries we install in
certain patients a
coronary androprosthesis which is a small tri-
metal tube designed to
correctly open the artery after the operation
an endoprote folded and placed on the
bloated  deflated during
positioning when the balloon is
deflated the stent unfolds and
secures in place after the
balloon and catheter are removed the stent
remains behind to keep the artery
permanently open
after the procedure a pressure bandage
is applied to the  femoral artery to
avoid bleeding you will have to
lie on your back for
several hours during which you
will be regularly monitored to
detect possible bleeding or
chest pain you can return
home the same day of the operation or
after a night spent at the  'hospital